[Music]
hello everyone Perry here again with
another San Diego comic-con exclusive
for you I have the team behind nos bra
two right here on the set I'm very into
the show but I want to start off with
you Joe right now because everybody at
Collider knows I am addicted to
audiobooks and I'm just fascinated by
the adaptation process and in particular
what it's like when you either watch a
movie or a show before reading the book
or vice versa so in your opinion what is
the ideal way to consume both forms of
this story I don't know that there is an
ideal way you know I mean sometimes it's
great to read the book first and then
see how they realize it on the screen
but you know I I actually saw Handmaid's
Tale before I read the book and found
that that in some ways the TV show
inform the experience of reading the
book in a really interesting ways I
don't know there's any wrong way to come
to a story I was hoping you would tell
me watch the show first and then read
the book because that's watch the show
first and then read the book thank you
or listen to an audio you guys should do
the audio book actually I think these
two would be great at audiobooks and I
definitely think they should find they
find it you know it's read for someone
do some stories I think that there's
something interesting about for our show
I think there's something interesting
about reading the book while you're
watching the show actually because
there's like I can't tell you how many
times in the course of shooting the
first season of the show where I'd be
like driving and I'd be like wait a
minute did that happen in the show or in
the book like there's so many overlaps
and overlays and things that are you
know echoes of the book in the show and
echoes of the show in the book and like
there's this real symbiotic kind of like
they're very similar but they also are
very unique and and so I feel like for
for somebody who hasn't come to the
experience of Nosferatu
at all that like the duality of those
two could be really interesting so that
you could do them at the same time
something I've never done before so now
I kind of wanted something new I like
that anyone can feel free to chime in on
this I am just fascinated by seeing
happy things like Christmas and clowns
subverted it to something that's
absolutely terrifying so would you agree
with that are you guys really in
- whether it's Christmas land in this
case I'm also really into things like
guerrilla and Krampus yeah I mean clowns
are terrifying just look at the
president oh no yeah yeah yeah way to
ruin the buzz huh
no yeah you know I mean I think that
that's sort of the job of horror fiction
is to take the stuff we love and trust
and then ruin it for everyone are you
guys into any any specific thing that
would really freak you out that's really
happy in your life right now that if it
became like a Christmas land
it might get under your skin a little
too much I feel like my dog I'm
picturing jumping off of that have you
guys ever thought of what your enscape
and knife might be because that's just
something that's been going through my
head a lot since I started watching the
show
what's your enscape I don't know I like
I just I really love Elton John and I
feel like it would have to be like maybe
I'd fly through like an Elton John land
like a skyscape of just like crazy
glasses and sequins and like head pieces
and I'd arrive at some magical
destination where all the music was
Elton's music I think that's probably
probably where I sit thank you I don't
know it's also called Rocket Man I wish
I've seen six times you have six yes I'm
gonna try and see it again somebody
asked me this before and I gave a really
boring answer so I was trying to think
of a more interesting answer I don't
think I can top Rocket Man maybe an Old
West town I like westerns maybe an Old
West
okay I'm taking my Mini Cooper and I'm
driving into Halloween town before
Christmas and
I have to ask about the makeup here and
in particular do you have a favorite
phase of Charlie Manx you know so
grateful to be reunited with Joel Harlow
and Ritchie Lanza who I've worked with
before on the trek movies and Cheryl
Daniels who does all of the wigs I mean
I just love them and so I guess I would
say that the longer I get to hang out
with them in the makeup trailer the sort
of I don't know I mean I don't know that
i love the 4-hour version so I'd say
let's let's dial it into like the middle
like the hour 45 version you know what I
mean where we get to really hang out
maybe we get to listen to a whole
podcast or a whole like episode of
something and then talk about it and
then I go to work rather than listening
to like a whole season of a podcast and
then I go to work which also happens if
you ever tried to use that aging face
app thing do you turn into old Charlie
Manx when you know but maybe we could
employ so that's not technology if we
get to do another season so he's pretty
dashing at about 55 yeah I think he's 65
at that sort of like guys Silver Fox he
reminds me of my neighbor growing up
like it's kind of my favorite it's my
favorite version of him he's the most
distinguished version of a sum of that
age I think it's true solid choice is
actually one of my favorite things about
Vic in this and also your performance
too is you are one of few that gets to
interact and have your own relationship
and chemistry with the entire ensemble
and really every one of them does stand
out but is there any kind of
relationship you've fostered through the
role that just went to places or brought
something out of you that surprised you
oh gosh honestly every single actor and
the entire cast has just been not only
brought out different parts of Vic but
the
friend I've learnt different things from
each person that I've worked with Zacks
like watching I mean watching Zach's
work I've spoken about that a million
times but also watching just the know
I'm talking about you in front of you
but just his kindness and the clarity
with which she kind of conducts himself
on set and how he engages the crew and
and the content as well so that's really
amazing Jakara and I just I mean we're
like best friends off screen as well
Virginia who plays my mom is just she's
a master class in acting and ebon who
plays my dad he's like I mean I honestly
sometimes forget the rest of the set
when I'm working with him I think the
family dynamic stuff is something that's
really stuck with me and affects me most
as an actor and then obviously diary you
plays being just watching him he's such
a kind human as well and just seeing the
kind of polarities that he plays with
with his character is just fascinating
so I'm lucky this was gonna seem like a
weird detail to harp on but every single
time your eye bleeds I am convinced that
like I get allergies and I rub my eye
I'm gonna look like that does it throw
you off and actually with you with the
nails too I always think about the know
that you're not used to having on you on
a daily basis do things like that kind
of throw you off it makes me really like
I can't understand women who like choose
that for themselves because it
complicates everything like it's so
weird
unbuttoning my shirt or buttoning my
shirt going to the bathroom is like it
is truly I just try to avoid it at all
cost don't drink anything it's bizarre I
don't know yeah there's a whole litany
of obstacles that present themselves
with those fake nails on that I never
had to deal with before this this show
does the bloody I freaked you out at all
well you know what putting it in I
actually it's really strange for some
reason eyes just it makes me nauseous
every time I have to sit there a couple
moments in the chair and I don't know
what it is it's just like a
hypersensitivity to
I will sell for something but the the
contact I said it happens for most
people it's a scleral lens so it's not
just a contact it goes through it goes
over the entire eye but I'm a terrible
I'm allergic to 49 out of 56 possible
Australian airborne allergens so I kind
of look like that when I'm in Australia
which is unfortunate seen as it's where
my Fath is I feel your pain everyone
that I'm with today was getting a dose
of me sneezing 100 times this morning I
did get the wrap-up sign but one other
thing I really wanted to bring up was
just how much Jakara stands out here and
then it was electric and when I see
someone like that in a show I have to
look up everything they've done before
so I could find more work and she's
nothing new to the scene so how did you
find her well it's funny I she made a
series of youtube videos as her alter
ego Sailor Jay they popped up on my
Facebook feed and if you haven't checked
them out you really should the first
month is contouring 101 and a genius
genius she is so smart and hysterical
and they're just really really brilliant
satirical little things and I became
obsessed with her watched all of her
videos and just thought she was kind of
brilliant and so wanted to meet her and
so said to the casting people before but
I get this feeling she might be great
can we audition her she came in and
auditioned and lo and behold blew
everyone socks off and got the part she
is phenomenal
I'll I have one more question do you
guys ever play Scrabble together for fun
and if you do who wins you know who
knows how much research he's done into
the part you've got to look up all the
the to the two letter words like Qi
that's a good one don't tell her about
that one key I'm not gonna try all I
have to do is plate and weird words with
friends and I'm good QQ what's a key
that's what I was gonna guess those key
if you guess the same and we're both
wrong I'll feel better thank you thank
you guys so much for your time today
everybody out there if you're not
watching nos router right now it is on
AMC 10 night central on Sundays it's
great you don't want to miss it I'm
gonna go cue up the audio book as well
guys again thank you for being here have
a great comic-con to everybody out there
like and share this video and stay tuned
because we're gonna have more Comic Con
coverage coming your way real soon